it's time for roses and roses a good
morning everybody we are doing a very
quick reaction because there's been
quite a lot of bachelor this week I
don't have any wine I have an empty cup
that will hopefully soon be filled with
coffee so that I can keep functioning
through this insane time in all of our
lives 3 our season finale we've just
found out that the bachelor finale is
going to be two nights confirmed by ABC
on Monday 3 hours live on Tuesday more
it's very stressful so let's talk about
the fantasy suite slash overnight dates
you guys first of all a direct quote
from Arie dune buggying is like a
relationship there's ups and downs
that's where we're at so you guys
kendall says that Arie feels like her
best friend and like she disappears with
him I think she meant this in a good way
but I love you Kendall and I don't want
you to disappear so don't
she is gonna leave those spoiler alert'
Arie sends her home okay do you like
some fluffy re goes over that hole how
do you like your eggs thing again with
Kendall just like he did with Lauren B
or ez which is indicative to me that you
know are the real important
conversations happening Ari's alluded to
like some really deep stuff with Becca
but we don't see those I want to see
those I don't want to know about the
eggs thing anymore
you were so lost you even know what kind
of eggs you like Ari tells Kendall but
he sent her home and you know I thought
about this if you guys ever told someone
you were falling in love with them I
haven't that just hit me
that's so deeply I'm thinking about this
franchise that I love so much at this
point I literally
my work right now I am just so stressed
out Lauren B says she's stressed out
still about the other woman being there
that her and Ari have a lot to talk
about I hope so
ari says that they're having a blast in
this helicopter and then to reassure her
because we're on The Bachelor ari tells
Lauren B okay he's also gonna tell Becca
that he loves her you know Becca was
shocked by this you guys are cooked and
so was I because I don't know I just
he seemed so into Lauren B and he said
he didn't want to lose her but then he
tells Becca that he loves her too and he
says he's ready to propose to Becca
Sandi's we knew Ari was gonna fall in
love with two women
but like I'm really struggling with the
fact that I can't distinguish and I
can't really tell who he feels more
strongly about shameless plug I talked
to the godmother of The Bachelorette
Trista about this and that interview is
gonna be up soon and easy online com how
she feels about when people say I love
you do to people mm-hmm ari says Becca
is the safest relationship interesting
Becca's ex comes in and he leaves
quickly and I don't care about him by he
looks great though for a guy who was
like I jumped on a plane to Peru to get
my girl I'm like wow well your suit
really matches your socks and you are
spiffy in that press linen okay so yeah
Ari is ultimately saying which I
appreciated in the promo he says that he
feels bad that both Lauren and Becca
feel good about where their
relationships are at that makes me feel
guilty we are all confused and then we
get the promo with the sobs and the
promise this will be the most dramatic
ending ever
I'm ready for it you guys I'm ready I'm
so ready I'm so ready because we are so
tired and if it is the most dramatic
ending ever I'm excited about it but man
I think we're gonna see some really real
heartbreak and also you guys check out
our exclusive interview with the
wonderful wonderful gal that is Becca M
she told me that she doesn't think Ari
is ready for marriage at all all season
long waking up with the Sun and ready
for marriage that's what he says let me
know what you guys think I love you so
much and the bachelor finale isn't
tweek bye